(audience applauds)
All right.
It is time for Drew's News,
your daily trip to the news forest
to forage for good news mushrooms.
Num-num-num-num.
(Ross laughs)
And with me at the desk,
best pilot in the biz or co-pilot.
Hey, you're a pilot,
we're each other's co-pilot.
I'm a fungi, to keep the mushroom pun going.
Hey!
There you go.
Ross Matthews!
Hi everybody.
Hi guys!
(audience applauds)
Hi.
I love this yel, yell-oh!
But guess what else is happening, Rossy?
What?
There's Bridgerton news.
(gasps excitedly) Oh my gosh, I know.
I wish we had our veils and our accoutrements, tiaras,
our favorite dreamy and steamy show-
Mm-hm
Is back on Netflix
this Friday!
Whoa
(audience cheers)
Took you long enough.
It has been a long time coming.
And Stylist reports that the director, Julie Ann Robinson
says what makes their sex scenes so different
is she shot them from the female gaze.
For example, she took that age old scene
that we've all been seeing,
a dude laying in a bed admiring a gorgeous woman's body
and flipped the script on it,
letting Daphne sit back and admire the duke in the buff.
Yeah, it wasn't just Daphne by the way. (chuckles)
And I love that,
I love that they're shooting this from,
flipping this script from the female point of view
and focusing on "let's objectify the men a little bit"
and hello, you know, who's watching Bridgerton?
The gays and the girls, so thank you.
(audience applauds)
(Drew laughs)
Right? I don't think it's big in the sports bar necessarily.
Yeah, no.
No.
Bridgerton in the sports bar.
I'd like to see that.
That's a flip of a script.
(audience laughs)
Let me tell you, I'd be there
Monday through Friday and on the weekends too.
Thank you so much.
Talk about a happy hour.
Ha!
All right, next up,
we've got a new trend at business schools across the nation.
This is fascinating.
Students are learning how to be happy.
Yeah, the Wall Street Journal reports
the hottest class at Harvard Business School,
heard of Harvard?
Is called Leadership and Happiness
and it's taught by Arthur Brooks
and he uses science, academic studies,
Buddhist teachings and Bible verses,
to help students learn how to cultivate their own happiness.
And he says, "happiness comes from
four key areas in your life."
Listen up.
He says "friends, family,
your work and your faith or your philosophy."
I think he's missing fun.
I would say you need a little fun in there too.
Can we add a fifth one?
(audience applauds)
Gotta have fun.
He says, they're all important though
and asked students to assess which areas
they might be neglecting,
because that's where they need to do their work.
And if you think about it,
those are the areas in your life where, you know,
you can have three of those four going right,
but that one little thing, you know,
if work's not going right,
it's hard to focus on the rest, you know?
I love that this class has been created and developed
and within seconds of the doors opening
and the seats being able to be filled,
(snaps fingers) attendance goes like that.
You can't get in.
Mm.
And I feel like this approach to the spiritual,
the mental wellness, the happiness,
our work life balance.
It's so funny that we go to these institutions
and we're not focusing as much on the life
as we are the learning.
Mm.
And um,
(audience applauds)
Interesting
I think what's great is to,
to see an appetite for it,
because maybe the way these students are coming in droves
to this class will make a bit of change
for them being more available.
And the thing about college, unlike regular school,
which makes me have an "aha" moment
about why the debate is so rich,
is because so much of college is elective.
Oh.
Versus lower schools.
So I'm glad to see this available.
Well, I am too.
I think it says something that
these happiness classes filled up so fast.
I mean, that's, there's a demand for it.
And as somebody who was forced to take calculus,
(chuckles) okay.
(audience laughs)
I could have used a happiness class at some point.
It would've been nice.
But I think that maybe them showing that the demand is there
will make other schools offer something like this as well.
And I think the word happiness gets a really bad rap
as if it is some lofty, hippy-dippy, silly notion.
Right?
And it is a war you will fight every day
and you will win if you find it
and you cultivate it and you harness it,
I think happy is very hard to achieve.
Absolutely, but it is worth it, if you can find it.
It is!
(audience applauds)
And we have to figure out ways in which to do that.
And it's different for everyone,
and it's a multi-layered thing,
and I'm glad to see that our wellness
and our excitement for life
can be fostered in a college community.
I think this is so good.
Yeah.
Life matters.
(audience applauds)
Absolutely.
I wish I could take that course, maybe we can?
(bright music)